[Música]
continúa la emergencia ambiental en
colorado eeuu las autoridades informaron
que cerca de 1.000 casas fueron
afectadas por los devastadores incendios
que azotan el estado el presidente joe
biden aprobó una declaración de desastre
para la zona
antes de año nuevo dejarán de funcionar
en alemania tres de las seis plantas
nucleares aún existentes en el país el
gobierno se convertirá en el primero del
mundo en completar la transición en 2022
la presidencia de sudáfrica considera
que los peores momentos desde la
aparición de crowe micro ya pasaron se
levantaron algunas restricciones y bajo
la bajo la presión al sistema de salud
bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo en
france 24 los saluda daniel hablando no
empezamos en eeuu y más precisamente en
el estado de colorado donde ya son cerca
de 1000 los hogares afectados por los
devastadores incendios que han golpeado
la zona según las primeras hipótesis de
las autoridades el origen de la
conflagración pudo haber estado en los
fuertes vientos que derribaron torres
eléctricas e hicieron que el fuego se
propagara rápidamente por el condado de
boulder los servicios de emergencia
informaron que aún a no ser popa no se
reportan víctimas mortales
el presidente joe biden
aprobó una declaración de desastre
este fue un juego rápido con ráfagas de
hasta 105 millas por hora saltando
instantáneamente sobre carreteras y
vecindarios
los residentes quieren regresar a sus
hogares lo antes posible para evaluar
los daños en muchos de estos vecindarios
que actualmente están bloqueados todavía
es demasiado peligroso regresar twitter
y el medio ambiente y el cambio
climático siguen representando uno de
los principales desafíos de la humanidad
la ong ambientalista greenpeace presentó
en vísperas del inicio de un nuevo año
un balance del 2021 y los retos para el
próximo año previamente hablamos desde
argentina con bruno giambelluca
coordinador de la campaña del clima y
energía de greenpeace quien no habló nos
habló de las principales conclusiones de
des informe y las tareas pendientes de
la comunidad internacional para luchar
contra la crisis climática
bueno las principales conclusiones son
que estamos viviendo una crisis
climática sin precedentes hay ejemplos
de esto digamos inundaciones aumento del
nivel del mar
pérdida de biodiversidad deforestación
necesitamos digamos tomar acciones
concretas particularmente los países que
se comprometen al acuerdo de parís
aumentar esas ambiciones para reducir
las los gases de efecto invernadero y
así poder ir controlando la situación
ambiental que tenemos tanto en argentina
como en el resto del mundo
bueno la última cumbre de naciones
unidas que se desarrolló en glasgow
escocia dejó digamos sabor a poco era
una cumbre en la que se tenía mucha
espectativa había sido suspendida por el
commit 19 pero lamentablemente las
ambiciones de los países fueron digamos
muy bajas necesitamos aumentar esas
ambiciones los países tienen que
entender que se vive una realidad
digamos grave
ustedes bien decían que hay desastres en
colorado en diferentes partes del mundo
y esos desastres digamos son
consecuencia de la crisis de
biodiversidad y climática que vivimos
hay que actuar cuanto antes si lo que
queremos es un futuro digamos sostenible
para las generaciones que vienen en
alemania- hoy se apagan definitivamente
tres de las seis plantas nucleares que
hay en el país las centrales de
productor james blunt y ground en el
norte de la nación europea verán el fin
de sus operaciones antes de la llegada
del año nuevo y las tres restantes
seguirán el mismo camino a finales de
la medida convertirá a los alemanes en
pioneros en abandonar la energía atómica
actualmente las fuentes de renovables
representan el 50 por ciento de la
canasta energética alemana
estas serán las últimas columnas de humo
que emane la chimenea de la central
nuclear de gundremmingen pues a la
medianoche del 31 de diciembre este
reactor del sur de alemania cerrará
definitivamente junto con las centrales
de grundy brutal en el norte del país de
este modo sólo quedan tres reactores
nucleares en funcionamiento que se
cerrarán a finales de 2022 la decisión
de eliminar la energía nuclear fue
tomada por la ex canciller angela merkel
hace una década tras el devastador
desastre de la central de fukushima en
japón
ahora los empleados de las tres
centrales alemanas comenzarán el largo
proceso de desmantelamiento de los
reactores con télam y me alegro de que
tengamos empleados en el lugar que
conocen la central que están calificados
y que saben lo que hace este periodo de
desmantelamiento durará seguramente una
o dos décadas más alemania- aspira a que
las energías renovables como la eólica y
la solar representen el 80 por ciento de
su producción en 2030 mientras tanto el
país planea llenar el vacío con gas
natural pero los precios de este
combustible fósil están subiendo
rápidamente mientras europa a una crisis
energética agravada por las tensiones
con rusia el principal proveedor de gas
del bloque y el canciller colapso se
enfrenta a otro reto el abandono de la
energía nuclear podría afectar el
objetivo del gobierno de reducir las
emisiones de co2 el ministro de
medioambiente ha advertido que alemania
no alcanzará sus objetivos climáticos
para 2022 y posiblemente tampoco lo haga
para el 2023 y el ministro de la
presidencia de sudáfrica mondo league un
qb le dio a conocer que posiblemente ya
pasó lo peor de la más reciente ola de
contagios del país africano el
representante del órgano ejecutivo e
informó además que se levantarán algunas
restricciones y que o micro ya no es una
carga tan grande para la salud pública
sudáfrica dice que su cuarta ola puede
haber pasado los nuevos datos muestran
que las infecciones por coronavirus se
redujeron la semana pasada en casi un
30% en comparación con la anterior
mientras que los ingresos hospitalarios
disminuyeron en ocho de las nueve
provincias a mediados de diciembre con
el aumento de la variante omicron el
país llegó a tener unos 26.000 casos día
según los expertos o mi clon ha
alcanzado el punto álgido con
manifestaciones clínicas que no han
provocado ninguna alarma en la situación
hospitalaria
y las condiciones permiten que se
levante el toque de queda el anuncio
llegó justo el último día del año al
tiempo que las autoridades han eliminado
la restricción de movimiento de
medianoche y han vuelto a permitir la
venta de alcohol una hora antes se
limitan además las reuniones a mil
personas en interiores y a 2000 al
exterior aunque sólo se ha registrado un
leve aumento de muertes durante el pico
de omicron se mantiene la obligación de
llevar mascarilla en los espacios
públicos la nueva variante del
coronavirus se identificó por primera
vez a fines de noviembre en sudáfrica y
botsuana ahora está presente en más de
100 países
hablamos ahora de francia en su último
discurso del año el presidente de este
país emanuel macrón advirtió que se
avecinan semanas difíciles con relación
a la pandemia del cob y 19 en esta
nación europea pero se mostró confiado
en que la vacunación podría ayudar a
salir al país de la crisis en 2022 de
semana venía las próximas semanas eran
difíciles todos los sabemos si es que el
virus está circulando y circulará cada
vez más el gobierno ha tomado medidas
para solucionarlo y les pido a todos que
se aseguren de que esto suceda sectores
como la cultura el deporte la
restauración la hostelería el turismo y
los eventos volverán a sufrir las
consecuencias económicas de esta
situación les ayudaremos como deberíamos
y como lo hemos estado haciendo desde el
comienzo de esta pandemia excepto de mí
y nos despedimos de esta emisión con las
imágenes que nos dejan las celebraciones
de fin de año en el mundo los primeros
en recibir el año nuevo fueron los
ciudadanos de la nación insular de
kiribati en el pacífico sur y se han ido
sumando varios países
[Música]
los habitantes de moscú la capital rusa
festejan la llegada del 2022 con juegos
pirotécnicos desde el kremlin la sede de
gobierno
[Música]
y en dubai la ciudad más grande y famosa
de emiratos árabes unidos- vistieron de
gala al icónico edificio burj khalifa
que con sus más de 800 metros de alto es
el más imponente de este lugar lleno de
rascacielos
[Música]
en tailandia una exhibición de fuegos
artificiales iluminó el cielo nocturno
de bangkok
a medida que el 2021 llegaba a su fin
aunque con estrictas restricciones por
la pandemia las oraciones de nochevieja
que generalmente se llevan a cabo en los
templos budistas del país se hicieron en
línea
en australia la tradicional exhibición
de juegos pirotécnicos fue protagonista
como suele ser en el sydney harbour
brigde como punto focal del espectáculo
para que el que se destinaron unas 6
toneladas de fuegos artificiales
y así nos despedimos de esta emisión en
france del 24 que les decía unas felices
fiestas y un feliz 2022